Hey everybody, welcome! Do you love comedy? Do you love to laugh? We'll buckle up because you're gonna fucking cry your eyes out. Welcome to SmartLess. Hi everybody. Oh, Sean, what a nice top you have on this morning. Yeah. Oh, it's look what's it say? I can't read it. It says, it says SmartLess and that's Hayes 20. Hayes on the back. It's our, Hayes 20, what does it say 22 on the back? 26, 26. 26. That's our birth date, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, so it's a SmartLess shirt. You can guess we're gonna get the freaking merch plug right at the top. Yeah, right there. It's right there. I'm wearing it. It's good to know that it's good to know that we make
it in a double XL too. Yeah. Good for you. You know what I mean? It's good. You got both boobs stuck right in there. No. Bang, bang, pow, pow. How's everybody feeling? Is everybody a little sleepy today? Yeah, a little sleepy. It's a little early. I could feel that. I could feel that. I, last, yesterday, I saw I'm in Tech Week. Oh, well, this is probably gonna air after we open. Well, what's Tech Week for? What are you talking about? Are you doing a play in New York? Is he in New York? At the Tabasco? So, at the Tabasco Theater. It's so spicy this show, y'all. You gotta go check it out. It's stupid. Anyway, the Tabasco Theater, David Bellasco was the owner and this I just found out yesterday.
I couldn't wait to share it with you guys. Actually, last night, because we're working like 12, 14 hour days, whatever it is. Well, I don't know how many hours, but it's long hours. A lot of people work. Seems like you do know them. Yeah. And so this crew guy comes because everybody has these stories because there's an apartment on top of the theater now that what's that? Oh, the crew guy. I think so. Crew guy. Yeah. Crew guys. There's an apartment on top of the camera. I'm like, Oh, these guys got a screw guy. All right. What kind of? I'm like, screw guy, please. And they just send one over right away. He's in over the screw guy. So the screw guy gets there. Oh, speaking of which, Scotty, Scotty
got his cue. You want by just as I said, screw guy. Anyway, like, see Scotty go by just shuffle by it in short. Anyway. Okay. So there's crew guy told me about this story because it's supposed to be haunted and below sometimes. And so David Blasco, who owned the theater years and years and years ago, there's this apartment on top of the theater that's now abandoned and nothing's up there. But he used to live there and there was an elevator shaft where he used to bring up, you know, lady friends over and over, right? And so one of the ladies fell through the elevator shaft and died. It's now like boarded up. And people say, and they call her lady in blue because people say they can see her
in the seats sometimes. How do you fall through an elevator shaft? I guess it was open and there was no elevator. I guess. I don't know. Boy, there was an episode of LA law once. I'm not making it up where the guys, I swear to God, it was on the, I just saw a clip of it recently and they're having a conversation about the elevator door and this woman speaks really tersely to the guy. She's like, so you better watch out, blah, blah, blah. The elevator door is open. She walks into the elevator shaft and falls, punches to her death. And the guy was like, oh my God, it was on TV. And that writer's room is like, how are we going to, what are we going to do in this episode? How are we going to, where is it
open? And she just falls through just like the lady in blue. Yeah. Have you hit fuck it yet on this, on this play? So I mean, it, it, it's a long run, right? It's been taxing for Jason and both Jason and me, it's been a lot. Yeah. So, but you haven't even started performances yet. You've been, you've been whacking away at it for how long now? You've already done it in Chicago for months and months and months. Now because it's so good and was so well received, you take it to New York, to the, to the hot and spicy Tabasco, and you, you're in rehearsals right now. You haven't gotten to the point of like, it's enough.
Um, no, I mean, you, you, as a, as a, You're discovering new things about it every day, right? Yeah, you do kind of. The surprise guest just mentioned, just, just, uh, Yeah, this is the surprise guest just tried to end it. Jason said, this is really interesting. Interesting. So maybe we should just start. Uh, I, I think he, it's a he has got comments on this too. Should we get right to him? Let's get right to him.
I mean, by the way, should we mention the plays open now? Yeah. I guess the plays open now by the time we work at the, at the, at the Belasco. Wait, what's it called? What's the play called? Okay. And did I like it on opening night? You would love it. It's called good night, Oscar. Okay. There it is. All right. Good night. Is there a comment there? There is after night and good night. I didn't know is two words.
I thought it was one word. And if you find yourself at the theater, watch out for a gaping shaft. Oh boy. Um, wait, I love that. We got to put that on the Sean list. So you thought good night was one word. I did that. Didn't you think it was one word? Probably not. Just like good morning. Has good morning ever been one word?
You know what else listener? Hang on Sean. Listener, Sean was shocked to learn that, uh, uh, John F. Kennedy was not shot in Washington DC or shot in Dallas. Because it's, it's stunning to me. You know what else listener is stunning about Sean? He was really surprised that Beatles, the group, the band. No, I'm not the only one that thought that didn't know it meant beat on a drum. BEAT.
Sean, I'm just noticing you're in your place in New York right now. And you guys, you've been there for a month now, but you don't, in the last couple of years, you haven't spent a ton of time there. No. But in that back shelf there, did you guys go to knick knacks or us? Load up on the knick knacks? That's a real Chatsky Haven. Hey, knick knack patty whack.
Look at your spider fern too up there on his own little, nice though. And that's feeling real well. All right, quiet down. Here comes a respectable guest. All right, look at a fella. Listen, this fella doesn't do this, okay? He doesn't do it at all.
He's trying to keep quiet and do his work. And while I haven't asked him, my bet is, is that he's dreading this and that he's thrilled that a full six minutes and 15 seconds are already over without him having to talk. My job is to make this as painless and breezy as possible. And I need your help, man, because this is a Grammy award-winning artist from Puerto Rico. And he's got a black belt in karate. Okay?
What? Most folks, however, know him as one of the best actors of our generation. So please say hello to actually one of the kindest, warmest, friendliest, most humble fellas I know. Let's welcome Joaquin Phoenix. Oh my God. Come on. Wow.
There he is. There he is. Hi, everybody. Hi. Wait, you're in a trailer, aren't you? Are you in a trailer? Yeah, so I'm on set. Oh.
Oh, for the Joker 2. Yeah. So I'm listening to the Jenny. You guys are on Jenny Power right now. Exactly. Exactly. Oh, that's the genre. Now, so then this is your lunch hour?
No, we're actually shooting kind of splits. So, you know, we're going to start in a little bit. So I just came up a little early. The beat from Beatles, is that really for beat, like drums? See, you dick. Yeah. That's exactly right. That was the impression I had to do with the beat poets.
Oh. Oh, I didn't even think about that. But no, it has to do with the beat. I thought it was the buzz. Sean, real quick, because Joaquin mentioned it, tell Tracy what splits are. I have no idea. Oh, bless him.
Bless him. They don't do splits on Will and Grace. No, it's always sensible. The best hours in all of showbiz. Which is like, it is the best. Split's listener is when you start at noon and you end at midnight. As opposed to if you shoot full nights, you start when the sun goes down and you end when the sun comes up.
Splits is kind of a half day, half night shoot. Yeah, that's perfect. Yeah, that's perfect. Joaquin, I don't even know where to start, man. I don't know you at all. We've never met and I'm such a fan. You're honestly, it's just, yeah. And I guess we, let's do it kind of like how we always,
what I want to know was what was the first of all, because you've done so many amazing characters and so many great movies, but what was the first, your first memory, like your first job that you did? First job I did was a guest starring spot on a TV show called Seven Brides for Seven Brothers, which my brother River starred in. And they were shooting in Northern California. And I think just by default, I think just because it was easy to get somebody local,
me and my sister played the small part in the show. And I think that was probably my first like significant job. The one time I worked with River, were you, I think you were, were you not in it too? We did the thing about the Kennedys. We played, we played like young Kennedys. I barely remember, I forget what it's called. Anyway, it was like a movie of the week or something like that,
about Robert F. Kennedy and his times. Did you play one of the, because you were so small, you probably couldn't even talk then, or maybe just barely, because we were like, we were 10 or 11 or something like that. Weren't we? Yeah, so I was six or seven. No, I don't, I don't remember that. I vaguely do now that you mentioned it.
It's like out in Massachusetts. I think the very first thing I did was, was that spot and then, and then, and then so the, the, so the acting to you as I, we're not, I'm not going to hammer you with your, all your fricking method and all that stuff, because I know you hate talking about that as, as, as do most. I don't know what it is.
I know, exactly. It's just, well, that's what my people ask me. No, I like that. I guess my question is, when did you get a sense that, that this acting thing might be a really comfortable thing for you to do and not something that's going to be a lot of work, you know, that it's not going to be like hammering nails?
I wouldn't say that it's very comfortable, but I certainly don't, don't care about that. I mean, I'm not, not looking for something that's comfortable. I'm looking for a unique experience. Yeah, you get it though, right? But when you see like, like Joaquin, when you, when you see an actor talk about their process and we've all seen it and people get into it
and they want to like focus, first of all, I remember doing this thing once and somebody was asking it like about, so we were doing Bojack Horseman and I got kind of, I think I was kind of a dick, but they were like asking about the process. And I said, why is everybody so obsessed with how the sausage is made?
Why can't they just enjoy the sausage, right? Like it's not that interesting. And, but then I see like, like, you know, these actors who talk, they spend a lot of time and you see them in these interviews and they're talking about their process and stuff. And I'm kind of like, okay, man, like if you want, you want accolades for what you're doing
and you want us to applaud the way you did it, like it seems a little self-serving. You have to forgive like everybody when they're doing an interview. That's true. Because you're just like, it's impossible, virtually impossible not to be an asshole when you're doing an interview.
At least for me, it's my experience. I mean, everybody fucking sounds stupid. That's true. There's just not a good way to come across. And oftentimes, like a lot of those quotes are from like when you've flown to go to like a film festival in New York and you're jet lagged and you have like a hundred interviews
and you start off just going like, I'm not going to do any of that shit. And within 30 minutes, you're just like, whatever it takes, just get me the fuck out of here and say anything. So like, yes, I read quotes from the interviews and I go, what a twat. And I go, I've done so much worse.
So I always feel like you have to give people like... I think you're, I'm with you on that. And that's totally fair enough. And yeah, like the interview and or junkie process is one of the worst sort of that you feel your soul leaving your body and you think like every word you say, you're like, God, I hate myself so much
for what I just said. And you're trying to come up with different ways to answer the same freaking question. You end up backing into a dumb answer. I think that what I meant was more that there are people, it seems like they go out of their way to consistently talk about that. And you're like, okay, that's what I was referring to.
However, having said that. Yeah. I mean, maybe, I don't know. I always think like whatever it takes, whatever works for you, it doesn't really matter. And, you know, I understand there are some, there are some roles that it feels like it requires you to, okay, for me, every time I work,
I know that I'm going to experience like an ungodly amount of humiliation. It's just, it's just how it's going to go. There's no way that I can get through it without being humiliated. And I think that's part of like letting go in some ways, right? Because it's kind of stupid. Like what we do is stupid.
Yeah. Yeah. And like surrendering to it. It is embarrassing. And like it's really difficult to do some things because if you actually step out for a second and you're like objective and you look at yourself, you just cringe.
So it's so fucking embarrassing and stupid. So sometimes I understand like you have to, I find that I have to like rush right into it and just go like, just humiliate me right now, make me feel like nothing. And so that I'm willing to do this thing. Because if I really think about it, I'll just be so embarrassed that I won't be able to do it.
It's like the stand up comic that goes out there on purpose and tries to bomb, you know, like to sort of rip off the bandaid and just like, I'm up here, I'm exposed, here are the jokes, or here's the non-joke. And that almost becomes a performance of just raw vulnerability and let's all get in it together. I always find incredible. Well, Sean said, Sean, you mentioned like surrender.
There is that moment where you do have to surrender. And I think that you do, like I watch you do all these characters in these movies over the last number of years. And I always, when I think about someone like you, I think like there's a guy who's like sensitive to the material. He's like, I would never want to be like, hey man, how did you do this scene? I'm like, he did a scene, how he did the scene.
You understood the material. You took it in, you were sensitive to it. And then you just like worked with the material that you were given. And that was your interpretation. That was your collaboration with the material, like full stop. Right. And it's also like, you know, journalists, critics, reporters, whatever, just kind of doing just enough of their job
to get you to fill in the blank and so, you know, with no thought behind it. I can't stand that. So how did you lose the weight for Joker? Here he comes. Here he comes. What about, do you remember your, when you were growing up, you guys lived a very sort of atypical adolescence,
like I did as well. How much of it do you remember? Do you remember what the policy was in your house about? Well, devices didn't exist back then, but TV and, or was it the kind of house where go outside, find a rock, find a stick and entertain yourself like it kind of was in my house? Yeah, I don't think we really had a TV until, you know,
until it was probably 11 or 12 or something. I don't know, maybe a bit younger maybe because we'd been working by then, but certainly when I was very young, I don't think there was even a TV in the house, but we did, there were five of us, right? So it's easy to entertain yourself when there's five kids, right? Same.
And my dad was always really amazing at finding houses to rent that were always like, you know, in LA, you can live like we grew up in the valley for a lot, and there's houses that are like by government land, right? There's just like mountain ranges, right? Like that's the backyards, so suddenly you could go there. And so that's what we enjoy doing, right? Just playing games and using our imagination.
So that's what I remember. And now, a word from our sponsor. Hey, listener, SmartList is brought to you by BetterHelp. Now, getting to know yourself can be a lifelong process, especially because we're always growing. We're always changing. And I'm not just talking about your ear size, your nose size, your nose hair, your head hair, or your foot size.
You know, my feet are getting wider and longer. How about that? Anyway, your brain also changes, and so does your heart. So to have an opportunity to process all this stuff literally at arm's length is incredibly helpful. Therapy is all about deepening your self-awareness and understanding because sometimes we don't know what we want or why we react the way that we do until we talk through things.
So BetterHelp connects you with a licensed therapist who can take you on that journey of self-discovery from wherever you are. And every time I've talked to somebody who has processed something, they're excited to tell me about what they've discovered, the new clarity that they have. You're just, you're lighter, and now you're ready to enjoy life or even just that hour a little bit more, right?
So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, suited to your schedule, just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapist at any time for no additional charge. Discover your potential with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month.
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by GameTime. Now, I have had very stressful moments trying to get tickets to a sporting event, concert. I'm just, I do everything last minute, and that is not something you want to do last minute. GameTime helps you with that. Buying tickets to your favorite events should not be stressful.
GameTime's the fast and easy way to buy tickets for all sports, music, comedy, theater near you. Killer deals on last-minute tickets and their best price guarantee. You can stop stressing over the tickets and start getting hyped for the fun you're gonna have. I mean, you know, we're right here, we're coming up on summer, and I just know there's gonna be a ton of great concerts
that I'm gonna kind of waffle on, where should I go, should I not go, and at the very last minute, I'm gonna finally either find someone to go with me or get the okay to go, and then I'm gonna try to get, and the seats are gonna be like weird, or who are these weird people that I gotta buy them from, and these, GameTime just eliminates, it helps dummies like me, okay?
So if you're a dummy like me, GameTime's for you, right? Is that a great sell or what? GameTime is the fastest growing ticketing app in the country for a reason. Get images of the seat before you buy, so you know exactly what to expect when you arrive. Buy tickets in a matter of seconds. Two taps, that's it, you're set.
Tickets are sent directly to your phone, so you never even have to dig through your emails. Anyway, listen, snag the tickets without the stress with GameTime. Download the GameTime app, create an account, and use code SMARTLESS for $20 off your first purchase. Terms apply, again, create an account, and redeem code SMARTLESS for $20 off.
Download GameTime today. Last-minute tickets, lowest price, guaranteed. I would like to just send out a quick thank you to ZipRecruiter for their support. Did you know that they support this show? Well, now you do. Now, I'm trying to somehow figure out a way to book somebody famous on this show.
You know, like, I wouldn't mind shooting for the stars. Maybe, like, how about, like, get the president of the United... No, we got him. Oh, how about, like, somebody from the Beatles got Poma Cartney? Well, anyway, if maybe if we're looking for somebody that you maybe you've never heard of but is super interesting,
yes, some place like ZipRecruiter could probably do that for us because they can get anything, anytime, anywhere to help your business, right? They can really help your staff up, and we need some guest staffing help here, so I'm going to give them a little ringy-dingy when I'm done with this ad.
It is very hard to turn down a personal invitation, so just imagine if you are hiring, or in my case, trying to book a show, you could send a personal invitation to the top candidates for your job. That would be great, right? Now you can, with ZipRecruiter's Invite to Apply feature. Right now, you can try ZipRecruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. How does ZipRecruiter's Invite to Apply feature work? Here comes the info. First, ZipRecruiter's technology finds and sends you the most qualified candidates for your job. Then, you can review this curated list and invite the ones that you're really interested in to apply to your job at the click of a button.
What could be easier? When you send out personal invites to your favorite candidates, it lets them know that they're one of your top choices, and they'll be more likely to apply. Makes sense, right? Invite ZipRecruiter to be your hiring platform. Four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day.
See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address. Get ready to try ZipRecruiter for free. Here comes ziprecruiter.com slash smartlist. Again, that's ziprecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. And now, back to the show. Forgive me, I don't know, Joaquin.
Were you, so you mentioned growing up in the valley. So were you born in L.A., like that was... No, born in Puerto Rico. Oh, that was true. Yeah, I was born in Puerto Rico. Oh, really? That was true. Yeah, let's see.
I think first we lived in... When we came to the station in Puerto Rico, we were in Florida. And then my mother was college roommates with Penny Marshall. Oh, Penny Marshall, yeah. Oh, wow, really? Yeah, and Laverne and Shirley was very popular at the time. And my brother and sister, my older brother and sister, River and Rain, would...
My brother learned to play guitar very young. And they would perform at talent shows and stuff. And they were winning these talent shows. Yeah. So I think they felt like this, like, just this curiosity and natural progression towards, like, something in the entertainment field. My parents didn't really have a lot of experience with it, right?
So I don't think they really knew, but I think that it seemed that the kids had... I don't know, I don't really want to say talent, but whatever the fuck it was, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Something, some kind of, like, creative spark. And I think they wanted to support that. And so my mom actually reached out to Penny Marshall
and said, we were thinking of coming to Los Angeles and would you meet the kids? And I think she said, don't, don't come out. You can imagine, like, somebody called you, like, from your past, if you went to college, it was like, hey, these kids, we're gonna come out and work when you meet them. And Penny's like, let me stop you there.
Yeah. No way! Please, please don't come out. And I think we packed up the next day. And I went to LA. And, yeah. That's fucking crazy. So what were your parents doing at the time that they're,
like, in, I think you said Florida, like, what was going on? My dad did, like, manual labor. Like, he was like the groundskeeper for this wealthy man. I think it was like a recording producer. I can remember his name. And there was a, us, like a little guest house
on the property where we lived. Wow. And my dad took care of the grounds. And my mom was raising us. And then we went to Los Angeles. My mom started working at NBC for this amazing casting director named Joel Thirm. Joel Thirm, that's right, at NBC.
And she worked there. And my dad took care of us, to care the kids. And we met Joel. By the way, let me stop you there just for one second. So Joel Thirm, for the listener and for you guys, if you guys, Sean, you may have met him, but maybe he was gone by then. But this was the office where when you were going in
to do a network test, which for the listener, that's the last step before you get a series as an actor. And when you get a series, you're employed for years and years. And it's like, when in the lottery, it's a high stakes thing. So that last audition, that last meeting in that office is Joel Thirm's office. So Joaquin's mom was on his desk. She was sitting at the desk right there where you're sitting
waiting, just like dying with anxiety, right before you're supposed to go in there. And it was like, to me, it's carved into my memory. That office, that little, that lobby, that section right there was where most of my anxiety started. So you're saying Joaquin's mom is so massive. No, no. But she was this ray of sunshine.
And every time I'd run into her, we'd have a very nice warm hug and smile. I love that. Yeah, she's... Wait, so Joaquin, so everybody was in it. Everybody was kind of in it or around it, yeah? Yeah. And so we would go and visit and Joel was always just so sweet.
He would just set us up in his office and we would watch. That's probably where I remember really being exposed to TV and shows, TV shows, was in Joel's office because we would watch all the reruns. He had every tape of every MCC show. That's so cool. Wow, that's so cool. And it was just like the best time going there.
And yeah, and I think we tried to do... I think he actually arranged for us to do some recording, like a test to see if we could do a show as a family. It was like trying to do something. Like a partridge family or something. I guess. And yes, he introduced us to Iris Burton, who was the child actor agent.
And the only one that would take all five of us. Because we'd met other agents. It was a package deal. And they'd be like, I'll take those two, I'll take that. She was like, I'll take them all. Wow. Wow, that's so cool. And so your interest in acting didn't really come as much from watching TV
or watching movies because you guys didn't do a ton of that when you were growing up. It kind of came from once you moved to Los Angeles and you started to get this initial exposure to it. Yeah, I mean, I think it just was an extension of the games that we played. My dad was a fucking ham. Yeah. Like he would do these skits all the time.
And again, because we didn't have TV, we just basically did plays. So we would just make up these kind of scenarios and play them out. Play dress up and shit like that. So I think it just was an extension of that. And then being on set, the energy on a set is unmatched. It's incredible, right? There's just like a hundred people that are all like brilliant in their own specific kind of craft.
Yeah. Right? So you've brought people that it's like incredible what everyone does, right? And there's such a, I think everyone in the best case scenario, one's really excited about what they're doing and they work really hard to kind of create this world. And that's a really interesting energy and it's fucking fun as a kid. You know, it's like, it's so exciting to be on a set.
So there was something that was just really enjoyable about it. And then I remember the first scene that we did in this TV show in Southern Brothers, Southern Brothers, and one of the characters, Peter Horton, was the actor. And we'd been friends with them, you know, because we'd been there on set. And so they were in the scene with him. And he's meant to get into a fight with the boyfriend of the woman that played our mother.
And they get in this like fight and they're rolling around the ground. And like to an eight-year-old, shit felt very real, right? And he was like, our friends, we were worried about him. And I remember being like overcome with this emotion of what was happening. And I distinctly remember like, like physically buzzing from it. And it was such a powerful feeling because it wasn't real. It was safe.
But like, I like had this feeling course through my body. And I was like, I want more of that. It was so fucking exciting. And nothing has ever given me that feeling. Like you're obviously safe because you're doing multiple takes. It's not then the world's a fucking movie, but it can feel so dangerous. You know, you feel like so much pressure because you're committing something and it's going to be around forever.
And there's something that just feels like really exciting about that to me still. That's so interesting. Hey, Joaquin, did you do any comedy? Always funny in what you do. Even if it's a drama, you'll find the comedy. But no, like a pure. Have you ever done like a pure again? Forgive me.
Have you done like a pure, pure comedy? I remember seeing you and to die for it. I thought that was darkly funny. Darkly funny. Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Die for it with Nicole.
Yep. I love that. That was I think in the 90s, right? Was that a great experience? It was a great experience. Yeah, well, I hadn't the last film that the last acting that I'd done was when I was, I don't know, 14 or 15 in a movie called Parenthood. And then we moved out of Los Angeles.
We moved to Florida. And I basically given up acting. Yeah, I didn't think that I was going to act again. And then I, then I, my brother really encouraged me to start acting again. And he was actually going to make a film and he wanted me to play his, his brother. And I think that kind of sparked my renewed interest in it. And then yet to die for came up. I remember going and auditioning for that.
I read that script and I instantly had an idea of, of what I thought. The character was and went audition for it. And I was always really fortunate. The directors that I worked with, a lot of them just didn't have ego and weren't desperate to like micromanage and control and really encouraged me to, to bring my ideas to it and to, to discover it. I remember it really started with Ron Howard on Parenthood. And I was surprised at how curious he was about my thoughts and feelings about the
character. So I just, I didn't know that that was allowed. And, and Gus was, you know, the same thing where I remember him just saying like, it doesn't, it doesn't matter. Like things don't have to go right. Like whatever happens is a part of it and it's okay. So don't worry about like any kind of rules in some ways. And there's a thing that you learn as a kid that you're supposed to pride yourself on,
which is like hitting the mark and finding your light and knowing your lines. And I think that all of that stuff is like really dangerous because it just like leads to things being flat. Like when everybody is just like hitting their marks and we know what's going to happen take after take, you just like, it's just human nature. Like inevitably you just follow it, fall onto something being like just wrote. And I think it lacks like an energy and excitement. And we're in this like unique position where you can do multiple takes.
So why not take advantage of it and, you know, let it be something different each time within a certain reason. And those are things that I learned from my early experiences. Like it's okay. I think because films are so expensive and there's so many moving parts, we like to try to control it as much as possible. Where do you sit on that? Because I battle with this as an actor and also as a director sometimes about, you know,
how much you should just sort of pay attention to the natural thing of it that you should adhere to the technical specifics of that particular shot. For instance, let's say the camera angle is really tight on you and you're sitting down and in the middle of the line, you have to stand up. And because you're in a real tight shot, the cameraman asks you to stand up kind of slowly. Don't shoot up because if you shoot up, I lose you in the camera. Again, I can't keep up with you. And so they ask you to kind of come up with sometimes they call it a groucho.
You kind of come up kind of slow like in a hunch. But certain actors, myself, sometimes I'll be like, well, no, I got to shoot up because I'm pissed off. Like, so either widen your shot or just anticipate. How much do you, like, are there times when you're a little bit more cooperative with that than other times? I mean, I find myself in that sometimes I just, I can't do it as a director. Sometimes I'll hesitate and even asking an actor to do it. But the shot might be, might really need it. Where do you sit with all that stuff?
The combination between the technical and the natural in what you do? I guess it depends. I mean, every film is different. There's not really one way of approaching it. And there are times where I think it makes sense that the other night we were shooting and camera was behind me. And I was moving towards the other actor. And just from years of doing it, I knew to, like, widen out a little bit to, like, favor the right side so that it was clear on them. And I remember as I was doing it, I was so ashamed that I hated myself so much.
And I was like, this means that I'm not in the fucking moment because I'm aware that camera's there. And then afterwards they were like, can you widen out a little bit? I was like, oh, I thought I was already widening out as much as I was comfortable with. And I was fucking embarrassed. And now you ask me to do it more. It's kind of our job though, isn't it? I mean, it's not part of it though, right? When you're doing theater, right, Sean?
You don't have to accommodate the other part of the process, which is the camera or the lighting or something. Like when we're doing movies or television, that is part of it. And I feel bad for pushing back on that as an actor. Like, my performance needs to stay pure and I don't even want to know about the camera. Yeah, but at every point of it, it is. Like if you're doing this show, Sean, I imagine, like you're always thinking about don't upstage, make sure, right? Yeah, all the time, you always play out. You have to play out.
And also there's faces staring at you. But it's distracting, right, Joaquin? Like it knocks you out of it. You've got this big monologue as Oscar Levant and that you're doing this moment at the same time you're thinking like, fuck, can everybody hear me in the back row? I'm sure you have those moments, right? Yeah, yeah, for sure. Yeah, it's terrifying. But Joaquin, it distracts you out of the performance though, yes?
Well, I think the job is to be as true to the moment as possible. And sometimes that's easier than other times for whatever reason. Sometimes I watch like basketball players and it's just like going in for them. And other times it seems like they're really working at it and focusing. It's just one of those things. Like sometimes you're in the flow and there's nothing. Those are the best moments when somebody can be making noise off camera talking and you're not distracted by it. You could throw anything at you and you're just in it because you're just in the flow.
And then there's other times where it's a bit more difficult. It feels like it's so artificial, everything that's happening. And I guess the job in some ways is to try to make it feel as organic as possible. And sometimes that's easier than other times. So I think if you're in it and you're in one of those moments, it's like, yeah, I can make that adjustment. It's not getting in the way. And there's other times where you go like, no, you have to adjust the camera because I can't do this. I don't really know why that happens.
It's that level. It's that thing you started talking about, about that level of discomfort and embarrassment of like, I have to kind of commit to this thing and to really commit to it is kind of embarrassing. It's just weird as shit and you're making that hard for me. But yeah. Yeah, that's what I want to talk about because all, you know, what I'm doing in this play is a big swing for the fences. It's like, this is embarrassing as all, all hell. Like I'm playing somebody that's nothing like me at all.
Yeah. And then, and then I see Joaquin play, do that over and over again. I'm like, gosh, how in the world do you get past that feeling of, you know, humility. Of leaving yourself so fully. Yeah, like over and over and over again. It's just kind of fascinating. I wonder if is the director, I would imagine is a big, big part of it, right? I mean, you've worked with so many incredible directors that so clearly have, pardon the term, a vision and clear, you know, leadership.
No, I'm not going to pardon the term. I'm not going to fucking do it. But is that, is that a big, big part of it for you when you're considering what to do next? Is it, is it, is it as much about the director as it is about the part or is it, is it more so? I mean, the director is it. Yeah. It's kind of that, that simple, right? Because everything ultimately runs through them.
Yeah. Even if they, they're choosing the cinematographer and the editor, everyone that they're working with, they're ultimately saying yes or no to which take is being used. Right. Especially because, you know, I, I like to, to do, to approach each take differently. Sometimes there's a lot of choices that the director has. And so you have to really trust them that they're going to make the right choices because sometimes I will, will do things that may not be right for the scene. And I'll, I'll, I'll know that. I'll know that this is probably not the right approach for the scene. But I'll do it partially just to, just to change things up, just to put me in this place where I don't really know what's going to happen. It suddenly just opens it up, the possibilities.
And there are times you go, fuck, I hope they don't use that one. Right. Or if they use a little piece of that with, with one that's, with a take that's more sort of norm, then it makes you look like a shit actor. So you really have to trust the, the ingredients that the director's going to use downstream when he's cooking things together or she. Yeah. Or it made you look like a genius. Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
So you use a little piece of something and, and you're like, oh, that was actually from an earlier part in the scene. That wasn't even my reaction for that line. Right. But that's like, that's great editing. So yeah, the filmmakers, everything. Yeah. You're so reliant on the taste of a director. Todd Phillips certainly has it in spades and you're, you're, you're the film that's coming out right now.
Well, Ari Aster, he seems like a guy is just, just overflowing with genius. That trailer is stunning. I can't wait to see that film. This is called Bo is afraid. Bo was afraid. How was making that because for, for, for the listener, it's, if you haven't seen the trailer, it's a correct me if I'm wrong. You're walking it. It's about a guy going to see his mom and the, the sort of the, the fear and sort of dreamscape or nightmare escape inside of his head as he approaches that event is where this film kind of takes us.
Is that a shitty enough explanation of it? Yeah, sounds good. That's just what I gathered from the trailer. But it's so, so it's very sort of fantastical and I don't know. I love sort of Spike Jon stuff and Charlie Kaufman stuff. And this seems in that, in that world and just another great example of that type of filmmaking. I'm so excited to see it. Did you love doing it?
I did love doing it. I have just great admiration for Ari and his, his approach and you're very early on, I realized like how perceptive and observant he was. And sometimes there are some scenes where you think like, okay, well, I can get away with it. Like, I can, I have no choice, but I have to act through this, right? Because this would be very difficult to maintain this for like six hours. Right. So inevitably there's gonna be a wide shot and I'm going to be acting in this one at the, at the end of the day, you know, and that happens if you once wanted something you really want to avoid. And it's horrible, but sometimes you're just so fucking tired and you can't do it. And again, the voice creeps in just going, this is stupid. What are you doing? Stop taking this seriously.
Yeah. Go home. Yeah. And so you have to fight that voice off, but it's very difficult if, if the filmmaker has that same voice and is also going like, hey, let's just come on and wrap this up. And I knew very early on that Ari was not that filmmaker. Right. And so I think that we, we were just constantly pushing each other to, to commit to it. Yeah.
As, as much as possible. And so there was no, there was no kind of like, oh, let's, let's cheat in this wide shot. We did one wide shot that was like, it's so ridiculously wide. And it's such a brief moment, but I had to like, I wanted to like collapse in the take. And I couldn't just like, drop to my knees. I just was like, this is just ridiculous. It felt like two melodramatic or something. Drop to my knees. And, and it was, and it was, it's stupid looking back on it. I was like, I could have just dropped my knees and nobody would have known the difference. But I, I just, I just felt like I was, I was cheating if I, if I did that. Wow.
I love how honest you are about that. By the way, Jason, you asked him the question, like, how was it making? And then you like took a moment to really, so often people are like, yeah, it was great. No, he's all honesty. I love it. No, it's fucking great. And it reminds me, Sean, how many late nights have you been like, we're not, it's getting too late and you just got to drop your knees. I mean, it's gotta be. I don't need a reason. I don't need the motivation. It gets me to sleep early. And we will be right back.
SmartList happens to be supported by FanDuel. Did you know that? Grand Slam's no hitters and double plays are back, y'all. And there's no better place to get in on the MLB action than FanDuel. America's number one sports book. That's because right now new customers can step up to the plate with a no sweat first bet up to $1,000. Just go to FanDuel.com slash SmartList, sign up, place your first bet and get up to $1,000 back in bonus bets if you don't win. Now, some of the ways you can use these bonus bets, you could, well, you could bet on maybe the over under on how long Sean's play is going to stay open on Broadway.
I would take the over, but I know the smart bet would be the under. No, that's not true. That's not true. I hear it's incredible. It's why it's on Broadway because it did so well in Chicago. So take the over. Now, what you can take the under on is how long will is going to fill in the blank. I was going to say something hurtful, but I'll let you do that right in your own hurtful mind. So don't miss your chance to get a no sweat first bet up to $1,000 when you join FanDuel today.
Just go to FanDuel.com slash SmartList to sign up FanDuel, official partner of Major League Baseball 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. Scammers are best known for living the high life, globetrotting on private jets, dining at five star restaurants and driving six figure sports cars. That is until their house of cards collapses and they're forced to trade it all in for handcuffs and an orange jumpsuit. Scamfluencers is a podcast from Wondery hosted by Sarah Hagi and Sachi Cole that tells the unbelievable true stories behind some of the world's most infamous scams, swindlers and con artists. Scamfluencers has covered jaw dropping scandals from Ponzi schemes to a fake Saudi prince to a sexual predator masquerading as a wholesome yoga guru. These scammers cost their victims hundreds of millions of dollars and immeasurable emotional anguish. So how does our culture allow them to thrive?
Each story on scamfluencers will take you along the twists and turns, the impact on victims and what's left when the facade falls away. Follow scamfluencers wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad free on the Amazon music or Wondery app. And now back to the show. Well, I was just thinking about years ago, I remember when Amy, my ex-wife was still on SNL and you came. I remember you came to SNL and you were shooting. You were with Casey Affleck and you guys were shooting. I'm still here.
Yeah. Yeah. So talk to me a little bit about that, man. Yeah, I was actually thinking about that today. I don't know why I was remembering actually being going to SNL because there was an actor that I ran into in the hallway and I can't remember who it was or I just don't want to say. And I was kind of like doing my shit for that movie. And she's somebody that I worked with and she's very shocked and concerned. And I remember like to look on her face, I so desperately wanted to tell her like, it's okay.
She's a thing. So we like made this commitment that we weren't going to tell anybody that it wasn't real. So listener, this thing that he's talking about, I'm still here. This was a documentary about Joaquin quitting acting and becoming a rap star. Wait, I want to hear Joaquin tell it. Well, write that in a nutshell. Everybody thought it was real. I have no reason to think it wasn't real and everyone was trying to be very...
Except that I was like 35 saying I'm retiring from acting to be a rapper. But that's what made it so electric is because everyone wanted to be really sensitive to, oh my God, what a tragic mistake this young actor is making. I can just tell you that at SNL that night that I was there, you were there. It was like late 2008, I think. I think Archie had just been born and you were like... And I remember you were walking in and you guys were shooting stuff and then I forget where the band was. And you guys came down onto the floor on 8H and you guys were shooting it. And I remember everybody in the cast was like, what's going on?
What is he... What is happening? Like nobody knew it was... Like you really had everybody... The train wreck is coming through. Fooled and like, yeah. But you know, it wasn't to fool other people like what we discovered is like... The moment somebody knew what was going on that it wasn't real, I became terrible.
Like I started being like really hammy and like winking at the camera. And I think the whole trip was to try to get it to feel as real as possible. And so the only way that it felt real was when other people believed it was happening. And it forced me to try to play it as believably as possible. And so that's why we just didn't want to tell anybody because the moment... Because there were some friends that... Like actor friends that I would do some scenes with. And they, because they knew me so well, they figured it out.
And I would inevitably just really start overdoing it. Just really kind of hamming it up. And so we just discovered like very early on that when I... If somebody thought that it was real, it just made me embarrassed and scared. And then I would just kind of be more internal with it and I think more believable. So then just don't tell anyone, right? Yeah. And it was awkward and uncomfortable. And this girl, this actress that was there, she emailed me.
Like a couple of these later. And she just said like, I know what you're doing. And I actually was so relieved. So relieved because I was so embarrassed. Did you respond? Did you confirm? I did not. I did not. Yeah. By the way, I tried to do this thing with this guy Bob, this writer yesterday on set.
And we were like, it's April Fools and we're like, and I don't do April Fools. But I was like, he was like, just pretend to fire me in front of the crew. And I was like, okay. And then so we got later in the day and I'd sort of forgotten about it. And then he walked out and then we started this argument and it got really awkward. But I had to commit to it because in the middle of it, I'm like, fuck. And it felt so like sort of status wise. I felt shitty.
Like an asshole. Yeah. And I hated that feeling. And I was like, why don't you get the fuck out? Well, why do you even bother showing up? If you're going to just pitch me shitty jokes and get the fuck. And I started going like that. Anyway, we sort of got to the end of it and I finally said April Fools after a few minutes
and the fucking crew, it got really quiet and it wasn't fun. No. And it made them all feel like comfortable. It fucking sucked. Wait, how did that all end up? I don't remember how that all finished up. When did the curtain come down on all of that? Was it on the release of it or?
Yeah, on the release. And at that point, we'd been shooting for like two years, I think, or a year and a half or something. And I was, I had been so looking forward to this moment of saying like it wasn't real. Because it had just been so uncomfortable. And I just had avoided so many friends because I just didn't know how to kind of like keep up the rules. And then so I can't remember how we kind of, you know, released it and said, oh, it wasn't real. Nobody believed us. They suddenly thought like, oh, yeah, of course, now after you fucked your career,
you're trying to say that this is like this spoof. Oh, they thought you like had regrets and come back. Oh, my God. No way. And so I was like, oh, fucking can't, can't win. Can't win over. But then you showed them what was up, what you came back with the master, right? Wasn't that, wasn't that what followed?
Well, that was, yeah, I mean, the thing is, is that as a product of this, of this, of I'm still here. I think at that point, a lot of people that maybe would consider hiring me were like, even if it's not real, you have to be kind of fucking nuts to do this. So he's probably, probably not something you want to work with anyways. And I remember my, my options. A PTA was like, bring it on. Yeah, my options at the time were just left a lot to be desired in terms of work. And I remember really at one point just really being desperate and feeling like,
well, I actually really fucked myself and I can't, I can't get a job. And I was really considering doing this, this movie that was a terrible movie. I knew it was terrible, but I was like, I just have to get back and show people that this wasn't fucking real. No fucking way. And I almost did it. And actually my agent, Boomer, who was actually, he was the assistant of my original agent, Patrick Weitzel. And he'd started working with me. At first I was like, oh, fucking bait and switch.
Like I'm working with your assistant now, this is bullshit. And then I remember talking to Boomer and I was saying, look, man, I'm just, I'm lost. I'm desperate. It's the first time in my life like I don't feel like I know what, what to do. And I'm asking for advice. I've never done that. You know, I always really have a strong sense of like what I want to do. And he was like, do you have to do this movie?
I said, what do you mean? He goes, does it matter to you? And I was like, no. He goes, well, then why are you doing it? And I really needed that at that moment. I just, I felt so fucking lost and confused. And it was really, it was a really important moment for me. And so I said no to the movie.
And then a couple of months later, Amanda Demi reached out to me and she said, hey, Paul's trying to get in touch with you. No way. And he sent the script over. I remember looking, you know, through the script and there was Freddie and Master. And I was like halfway through and I was like, there was no way he's calling me for one of those parts. You know, so I called him. I said, what, what character am I supposed to read? Because I figured it was like something that pops up, you know, for a couple of scenes.
And he was like Freddie. And I didn't even finish the script and I had to prevent myself from saying like, yes, right there. So I was halfway through and I was like, just fuck. Yeah. I couldn't believe that he wanted me for that. That's so cool. Well, that's, that's, before we let you go, I want to ask you just real quickly about Napoleon. And it's one of the movies I'm looking most forward to seeing coming up. It seems like that was a really robust shoot.
I mean, period and Ridley Scott and that subject matter. I mean, was it as epic as it sounds like? What can you tell us about that, if anything? Yeah, it was, it was a fucking massive production. The amazing thing about Ridley is he's like overseeing this massive machine. Like just like hundreds of extras, eight cameras, you know, these huge locations. And he can just pivot like, like that. Like he could arrive on on set and make a discovery in the moment and feel like the scene is maybe leading in like a new direction.
And he's just fine. Like he will adjust, he will adjust the camera, he will adjust to the performance. Like if there's something that feels honest and real and like a worthwhile exploration. Turn a steamer ship around. And it's so impressive to me. Because yeah, I mean, I don't know how much we were spending a day, but it was, it was a lot. And I had a great experience with him, you know, all those years ago on Gladiator. And so I just was always, always wanted to work with him again. That's so cool.
You know, I know we're going to let you go because you're going to get back. But, you know, hearing you talk, I've never met you. I know you probably hate this, but I'm a huge fan of yours. And you are an inspiration to me and tons of other actors. So much respect for you. I know you hate that because it feels false, but it's not. But you're married, you have a baby boy of purpose with animal rights activism. You have a great career.
You have all this stuff going on in your life. Are you able to sit back and just kind of absorb all that? Or do you have a defense mechanism where you're just like, no, I got to, I just, I know everything's great. I just got to keep going. I just got to keep going to challenge myself the next thing. Or can you really sit back and absorb all the great things that have happened to you? As you get older, it all becomes easier. I'm fully cognizant of what a charmed life I have.
It has exceeded my expectations or my greatest dreams. I'm so fucking grateful for what I have, the family and friends that I have and the opportunity for work. I never imagined it would be like this and it has been so fulfilling. So I really do appreciate it and value the opportunity that I've had. But I just want more experiences. I just love making films. I love collaborating with people. It's just so exciting to talk about makeup and hair.
You're sitting around with all these people that are really good at what they do. You get to kind of create something together. It's just an incredible opportunity. I love that you said that. You said it before when you were talking about all the people on set. I don't think people appreciate enough. I love that you said it. Everybody on set, no matter what their job is, everybody is a filmmaker.
Everybody is part of the process in that way. Too often, you see people who don't spend the time of the energy. Every single person here is making this film together. There's nobody there that doesn't have to be there. It's something a lot of people don't realize. Walk your incredible at it. Please keep going. We'll take twice as much.
But I know you got a kid to raise and Rooney to hang out with. She's awesome too. She found us our dog. She found us our dog, Gary. He's a real cutie. We love you and thank you. Say hi to Todd and Larry. Have a great day of work.
I hope this has been okay. It's been awesome. Before you go, how do you get into Joker? We ended up talking about the process and nobody got hurt. No, but in a good way. Thank you for taking the time. Very nice to do this, buddy. Thank you guys.
Honestly, this was painless. Painless. Kind of. When you're done, hurry home and we'll talk some more. Okay, great. Thank you all so much. Have a good day. Bye walk.
Man. Amazing. That's an artist. This is an actor. Did you know him, Jason, for a long time? Yes. We don't spend every day with one another by any stretch, but we've known each other for a long time.
We've got some very close mutual friends. He's a guy I would love to talk further with, deeply with, at length with, but as you can tell, he doesn't really enjoy talking about the stuff that we're all fascinated with about him. And that's probably why he's so goddamn good at what he does. Maybe he just doesn't care to look at how the magic trick is done. It's something he's great at.
It's something that he enjoys. That's what I was getting at. I forgive those people for talking about the process, but I meant more about the people who go out of their way. They're like, look at my process. It's so difficult what I do. That's what I meant. When they offer it first.
Yeah, when they offer it first and they're like, my whole thing, my whole identity is wrapped around how I do it. And I want everybody to know and to think that, and be impressed by my process, which he is like, there couldn't be further removed from that. He's like, man, I don't want to tell you anything. He's also one of those actors I love watching and trying to understand what that character must be thinking.
He's a very internal actor. And you kind of, if I knew what he was thinking, and I knew how he was doing it, or if I knew that much about him, if he did a bunch of press and all that stuff, it'd be hard for me to buy him being somebody else. So I kind of liked that he's mysterious. When you watch him do like,
I was thinking the last thing I saw him in was Joker, and you watch him in that performance. Amazing. Yeah, incredible. And, you know, millions of people love it. Some people don't. Whatever you think that when you watch him, he's so compelling, Jason, like you say,
because you're like, what is he? He's so inhabiting it in those moments. And he has these moments where he take, and you're watching and you're thinking like exactly that. What is he thinking? How is he, where is he now? Where it says he's more into the work than all the other stuff.
But he's also, I don't know. I mean, if... It sounds so fucking accurate to say, but... He manages to do something that I love when I watch actors is their ability to communicate vulnerability and humanness and flaws and elements of being broken because we're all broken. We're all vulnerable,
but we all learn these different, you know, skins of trying to like hide it. And he is so courageous. Just as a person who was talking about making a fool out of himself, of being kind of warts and all, like look at all my flaws, and he finds those in every character because that's all part of it, I suppose,
is just being not fully put together, you know, with his characters. He's only the second, but he is only the second guest we've had who is Killing Sigs during the interview. Oh yeah, Sean Penn was the other one, right? Yeah. Killing Sigs. You haven't smoked yet during an interview, have you?
No, I did when I was in London, remember? I was recording from London. I did a couple of times. So that was, what was that called if you smoke a cigarette over there? Oh, crushing. It's not crushing, but it's crushing. Don't say it.
Don't say it. We'll have to lift it. We know what you're going to say. Jesus, Sean. Don't say it. I was just curious. I don't know what it's called. Sean, you're trying to bait him into a cancellation.
Are you looking to recast? You're looking for a new third? No, you can crush some facts over here. Oh, she says, Sean, for fuck's sake, what is wrong with you? Well, I'm talking about, what would the term be, what would the term be, though, speaking of which, if you liked men and you liked women? Yeah.
That makes you... Oh, that would be bye. Guys. We haven't done just a straight up bye yet. Oh, I know. Smart. Right. Smart.
Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbicot, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music,
or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.